[Music]
[Applause]
brady if the browns needed you
this weekend against the raiders
could you help them if they simplified
the playbook yeah yeah i mean ironically
i'm actually in the state of ohio right
now back home in columbus so it wouldn't
be too hard of a trip to make that
happen so uh
anything for the browns now i might take
a little while to get warmed up
but once i get in there yeah i'd do
anything for the brownies what do you
think is going to happen here did we get
to the point where we have to pause the
season
i hope not i mean
look i'm not a medical expert by any
mean means but there was a show called
dr quinn medicine woman so i will try to
put that hat on for a second um
you know at some point we're gonna have
to handle and i think the nfl is coming
to this conclusion as well as the nflpa
for that matter asymptomatic cases
versus symptomatic cases and as we move
on you know if we're going to be putting
players out there and the players
obviously realize they're at risk at any
point in time by choosing to play
um you know we need to realize that as
much we can test everything we want
there's still going to be players who
still can track the virus through
whatever means now we haven't seen a
case where it's happened during a game
but obviously during the weeks in
practice and in their social time that's
where this is occurring
but the truth of the matter is they're
going to have to start letting players
play who are asymptomatic it may sound
controversial but at least to the best
of my knowledge and everything i read
from medical experts you're not a risk
then to passing it on and and really
let's be real about this if a player is
asymptomatic that has the flu virus in
them
those countless guys have played i
played in games where i was sick but
still wanted to fight through and play
for it so i understand we want to treat
kova differently because of right now
everything that's happened in the past
couple of years but at some point
every professional sports who's gonna
have to start looking at it similar to
how we've looked at other viruses in the
past um but i still don't understand why
we can't go to a model where we play on
a tuesday or we play on a wednesday like
i'm the type of guy that loves football
and when we did it last year i thought
it was actually a great experiment to
see like hey let's start to put games in
prime time on tuesdays and wednesdays
and let's see how they perform uh i
personally like that a lot better than
cramming a bunch of games at one o'clock
or four o'clock on a sunday where we
could sit down and really have a chance
to watch tennessee or buffalo like we
did a year ago
and for all those gamblers out there
there's probably a little more action
too on that specific game
we were just talking about how many
teams are set at their quarterbacks
quarterbacking position so there's no
doubt about it now i'm factoring in the
packers with aaron rodgers you know
that's not gonna last much longer ben
with the steelers that's not gonna last
much longer even brady with the
buccaneers is maybe you know two or
three years away but
you got mahomes and you got justin
herbert those two teams are set
uh you're set i guess in jacksonville
with trevor lawrence
new england with mac jones
um
joe burrow california yes uh are you sad
are you set in cleveland
i think they are
i think they'll eventually end up
agreeing to a long-term deal now i might
be in the minority there now you didn't
mention josh allen he's the other name
that comes to mind and baltimore with
lamar jackson baltimore lamar jackson um
so those are the two i personally am a
baker fan i think
he will get that long-term deal
eventually
uh and i think they can win with them
and this year he's playing with a lot of
different things going on um so
you know that that to me is one in that
category uh outside of that i'm trying
to kind of search through you know the
raiders with derek carr
he's put up tremendous numbers there
i think he's one of the more underrated
quarterbacks
in the nfl given everything he's dealt
with on the field off the field their
roster the defense has been atrocious
they're better this year but that's been
a team that struggled mightily out
around him he once again doesn't have a
number one wide receiver as good as
darren waller is that's still the tight
end spot you still need a compliment to
that much like we saw last night with kc
with with tyreek hill and travis kelsey
so he's another one who i've thrown to
that category and that may not hit
people the right way but
i'm sorry you put him on some of these
other teams i think he's going to have a
more successful career in regards to
wins and losses dak prescott's also in
there the cowboys better be set given
what they're paying him um
is seattle set at their quarterbacking
position
well yeah i mean he falls into probably
the ben rossberger category right like
they're they're set for now but yes you
know i just don't know how
i don't know how you leak out what
happened last year in the offseason and
then think that like every off season
you're not gonna have to answer this
question until
something else happens and and look i
think there's a lot of questions like
for the new york giants are they buying
into daniel jones if not
i am
swinging for the fences and fly taking a
private jet over to seattle and seeing
what i could work out to get russell
wilson the new york giants because i
think there would be mutual interest you
know i think he'd love to be in that
market where he's not you know caught up
in the pacific northwest where
you can't even get an mvp vote for as
good as he's played
and i think you put him on that team
with the roster of talent they have out
around him and an offensive line that
struggled but i think through the draft
next year they could get better but also
his mobility can make it better i just
think he all of a sudden skyrockets the
giants back up to where they want to be
and that's probably competing for
division at super bowl would you take
derek carr or kirk cousins
oh that's a tough question
oh man
i mean
how many games are on monday football
[Laughter]
so if i don't have him in prime time
you're going to take care one o'clock
games kirk cousins
there is something to everyone's
circadian rhythm right not to like try
to talk about people's heads but maybe
he's just like
better planned for those one o'clock
games maybe even four o'clock games than
prime time on sunday night monday night
thursday night all right let's dissect
last night i mentioned a couple of
things that i'm i'd love that to
chargers go for it on fourth down i i
think it sends a great message to your
team that this is who we are and i have
confidence in you
the going forward on fourth down at the
end of the first half i didn't
understand because
if you don't make it then you have the
chiefs in horrible position well the the
half is ending brady it's over you gotta
kick a field goal in that situation the
other ones you want to go for it fine we
can maybe nitpick on the play calling
but i had a problem at the end of the
first half not getting three points
and and i wonder how much the the fourth
down earlier that was dropped that they
could have converted for a touchdown how
much that played into it right like they
should have scored a touchdown that they
should have converted that and thoughts
and prayers too i'm so hoping the player
is okay but you know the reality is i
wonder how much of that played a factor
into the feeling of all that because i'm
with you i'm thinking in my head just
take the points move on to the second
half this isn't the time to take that
risk necessarily but you know you also
have justin herbert as your quarterback
and i think
the message he is sending and and you're
right it's it's the entire team like
it's the justin herb in your offense
saying we think that highly of this kid
we're gonna give him four downs in a lot
of circumstances not three and that
might change the way we look at football
or how teams approach us but
it's gonna change the way i think a lot
of people look at football especially
when you got a quarterback like justin
herbert but it's also telling your
defense if we don't get it we believe in
you yeah being able to get us the
football back to this guy so but explain
the analytics though brady because
analytics don't factor in it's patrick
mahomes and travis kelsey and tyrek hill
going forward on fourth down you know if
if this is jacksonville you can't use
the same analytics
i personally hate even the analytics
conversation because i think it's too
nuanced there's too many variables i
mean for starters your game plan alone
changes drastically week to week with
the personnel groupings you want to try
to utilize to find that matchup versus
your opponent their scheme you know
depending on what type of cover three
zone they play teams play them
differently so how you go about
preparing those route concepts are
different the blitz packages are
different so in all those scenarios and
you better believe on fourth down in
particular
we would you know we put on the game
plan got to have it plays there's some
teams are going to bring the house
depending on where you're at especially
that on the red zone there's some teams
we're going to play all covers they're
going to drop eight so you have
different you know a different
preparation for each one of those so
there's so many variables just with your
opponent
and that situation let alone your own
personnel and who's out there and that
match up and how your personnel matches
up against them and then injuries and
everything else and flow of the game
i think last night's decision by brandon
stanley was more flow of the game he saw
earlier like we should have had that it
should have been a touchdown we feel
confident about what we're saying let's
go for it here and by the way we are
playing the chiefs
so maybe if they're playing the jets as
you said you take the points you move on
but because it's the chiefs you kind of
feel like we have to take these chances
of scoring touchdowns we can't afford to
take our foot off the gas at any point
in time yeah and i understand that that
the chiefs get in your head more than
any other team in the nfl where you go
we got to get we got to get touchdowns
down field goals and i understand that
philosophy but at the end of the first
half i got to have points i don't want
to go in that locker room going man we
failed on fourth again
do you did patrick mahomes have a great
game good game or just okay game last
night
uh i thought he had a good game i
thought he had a good game i don't know
that i call it a great game i thought
the fourth quarter was was great for him
they're kind of towards the end i mean
besides one one pass in particular it's
gonna get a lot of play i mean it's
funny yeah you can have a great game
but as a quarterback when you have that
one bad pass that like easily was a
layup for you and you miss it you burn
it into the ground like that
it's hard to ever come away saying it
was a great game like you could you
could barely miss it you could be just
off maybe you feel better about it but
when it looks that bad when it's that
wide open i don't know that you'll ever
come away saying it was a great game so
it was like it was a good win it was a
good game for him uh but the scary thing
is i still think like the best is ahead
for this team and for this offense right
now okay if i said paige you know
patriots got the colts coming up this
weekend on saturday
better team right now in the afc
patriots or the chiefs
chiefs
i just i think they're too talented the
run that they're on right now i love
look i love everything that you know
bill belichick has done this year i
think you know i'm kind of in the cliff
kingsbury category or you could probably
give it to bill belichick every year but
this at least in my lifetime may be the
best coaching job that he's done
because of everything he did back in the
offseason the way this defense has come
along this year bringing along mack
jones and just you know getting mack
jones where they got him they didn't
have to trade up to get him they sat
where they were they take him and they
plug him in an offense that plays to all
his strengths and they surround him with
some playmakers which obviously was
needed but you know i kind of look at
where they are right now and i wonder
you know can they beat an indianapolis
team that's going to try to run the
football down their throat create some
big plays in the past game with carson
wentz
uh and it's hard to buy into that where
if the chiefs are playing the colts
i don't have any reservations about you
know looking at the colts quotes are
probably excuse me the chiefs are
probably favored in that matchup you
know whereas now you're looking at the
patriots they're a two and a half point
underdog so that's where i think the
difference is when you compare those two
teams right now is the chiefs get the
benefit of doubt because of how
explosive their offense can be
the
best team in the nfc right now is
green bay packers okay i think the way
they're playing right now i'd put them
in that category i mean the bucks are
are right up there too it's kind of hard
to say that and
you could have made that argument for
the cardinals but it was a pretty
damning loss on monday night i mean they
got physically beat up that that score
wasn't indicative of how that game felt
just watching it and really from the
first step where aaron donald wanted to
kind of prove a point uh like people
people maybe forgot about me as far as
this discussion of the best
defensive player in the nfl like michael
parks has been phenomenal but it's like
hey i've been here for a while i've won
multiple awards for this uh don't forget
about me either so that uh that made me
feel like hey maybe we should worry
about the rams all of a sudden becoming
a sleeping giant as they build some
momentum moving forward he's brady quinn
the former notre dame and cleveland
brown quarterback he's uh with two pros
and a cup of joe that's the morning
program on fox sports radio with levar
arrington and jonas knox 6am to 9am
eastern i want to be fair to you with
the urban meyer quote that you had this
was prior to him getting fired
but you were
i think basically calling out the media
that were being unfair to urban meyer i
don't want to put words in your mouth
that's why i'm gonna i'm gonna leave it
to you to explain what you meant by it
yeah i think the quote i had got taken
out of context a little bit because i
said it was applied to all college
football coaches
any time and you can look at the track
record for cliff kingsbury go back and
look at the quotes when he first got
there people questioning hey why does he
deserve to be here
he had didn't have success at the
college level at texas tech why should
he be the head coach of the arizona
cardinals you know we we tend to
question those guys matt rule you know
why is he here you know why is he in
carolina
which you know looking at what he did
from year one to year two they've
already equated the same amount of wins
the quarterback position has kind of
been a disaster this year yet they still
end up probably improving having at
least one or two more wins when it's all
said done they did a year ago
and so i always just wonder why the
media tends to be
so negative or pessimistic about the
opportunity for a college coach to come
in and do the job now i'm not naive
enough to think that just from playing
in the nfl that there's not drastic
differences between the two and you
might need to give that college coach a
longer leash a la look at cliff
kingsbury how about them apples how's
that working out right now
but i think that was the similar that
was the similar statement i'd make for
urban meyer is
there are people doing victory laps
right now dan like they're going back
for a fifth year of college because he
got fired i'm like i don't know what
head coach in 13 games who might i add
he did surpass their win total from a
year ago
is turning around that organization
they've been a bad organization
for a while they've drafted in the top
10 every year since 2008 they're not
they haven't been a good organization a
good football team for a while with the
exception of one miracle season they go
to the afc championship game
and so to think that in 13 games
a coach who's never coached at that
level before is gonna figure it out
i mean you call it naive call whatever
you want but the reality is no one gave
urban meyer a chance on the way in with
at least the way the media talked about
him and what that means is they never
gave him a chance to make mistakes now
granted he made a lot of mistakes like
especially from the public ones and
things that you know he has owned up to
and the things that he did
but i think shad khan had to have
realized when he hired him and he
pursued him by the way for a while i can
trust me on that
i think he he had to have realized what
he was getting himself into like this
wasn't going to be like a year year one
turn around maybe not year two maybe by
year three or four
so you know there's a lot of parts to
blame in all of this
but i think how the media in general
treats college football coaches trying
to come to the nfl level and make that
jump to me is always with this era of
pessimism and meanwhile we give other
coaches passes like zach taylor who won
six games his first two years and that
what were his qualifications coming into
it now they look better now than large
parkers and joe burrow on that roster
but it's just odd how we handle the two
but also it's it's really
inside the organization that i think
people had a problem with it was urban's
style
and you know
you can you can
nobody said anything about zach taylor
and his personality in cincinnati
but then the expectations weren't where
urban was we expected oh here comes
urban okay mastered college he's going
to do in the nfl it was the personality
traits that came out
i didn't think he was the right guy for
the job i don't think he's a pro coach
you got to get somebody who understands
how to develop you know trevor lawrence
said that from the beginning ryan day
would have been a better coach than
urban meyer with jacksonville and i
firmly believe that not even factoring
in the personality part of this he's
younger and he'll develop a quarterback
better than urban would it's the
personality traits that came out brady
and i think that's where people had a
real problem
well first off i'll say this he has
success everywhere he's gone yes so the
biggest issue was you can get away with
coaching pretty much whatever way you
want when you win
but when you're hard on people players
coaches as well and people in the
organization in this case
and you're not winning that's when it
becomes an issue because winning cures
all illnesses you can have a terrible
working relationship with someone but if
you're hitting your quota in sales or
you're making a bunch of money or you're
winning football games
you can deal with it like life's good
but in this case that wasn't okay
everyone feels miserable and look i was
on you know bad football teams in the
nfl and it's a hard
hard thing to deal with on a
week-to-week basis when you're not
winning football games it really is and
so i think one of the hardest things
that he had to figure out and learn and
he never had enough time time to do it
was how to lose like how to learn from
your losses like that's like a great
life lesson for people yeah it's like
it's not the worst thing to lose it's
just you got to learn from it and he
never really lost
i mean what was he like 187 and 32 in
his college career coaching i mean think
about that that's staggering in the nfl
you know nowadays with 17 games right
you're 10-7 you're in the playoffs and
you've nearly lost half the amount of
games you played nine and eight may even
make it who knows but
that's the reality is i don't know that
he ever was given time to figure that
out
in 13 games
and and i don't you know maybe that's
more the question i think the other
thing you point out about ryan day is
ryan day is more of hands-on with things
he's not like the ceo type coach he's
going to be a part of the play calling
he's going to be a part of that
quarterback room and developing
cj stroud or whoever the next
quarterback will be at ohio state or
whoever's already been there you know
coach meyer has more of a ceo type of
town he lets his coaches coach but they
have to bear the responsibility for the
decisions that they make and how their
installs their scheme what they're going
about doing what's he doing
what's urban do next
well i would not i mean i don't know
he'd probably join us at fox at some
point that'll be my guess you know he at
some point comes back on our desk um
i don't know that i reached out to him
haven't heard back from him yet which
obviously i'm sure he's he's dealing
with a lot but if bob
bob stoops is leaving the fox pre-game
show
right well i i mean if he was i don't
know that i mean that'd be news to me
but um you know who knows maybe we'd
create another chair for him or if coach
stoops did leave then i assumed you know
there'd be a spot there for coach meyer
maybe they'd add a spot for him i don't
know um i enjoyed working with with him
i enjoyed working with coach stoops so
you said you wanted a barrier you wanted
to get rid of liner so you could get
liner out of there and then you could
scoop soon
first off matt and i are probably the
closest up there on the set together so
don't go trying to drive you can say
that you can say that publicly what we
talk about behind the scenes my bad
should have stayed off the record yeah
by the way by the way dan thanks for the
christmas card it really was heartfelt
that you decided to reach out and send
us a christmas card you are welcome you
are welcome i can't keep track we are i
can't keep track of all the houses that
you have you know you're all yeah all
over the place all the places you played
you know that's like 10 places so you
got a house in seattle and who knows you
know la
florida ohio
yeah that was actually never owned a
place in seattle but that was probably
the most difficult moving out from that
place
uh because the place i was running the
landlord was really upset about it and i
remember saying to the landlord like you
think you're upset like i've never been
cut before how do you think i feel
like i've been in the nfl seven years
now it's the first time i've been cut
i'm almost 30. like how do you think i'm
feeling right you think i'm worried
about whether or not like you get your
deposit back i don't care
i'm trying to figure my life out right
now you know but
this landlord was like oh oh you know
and now we're not trying to get on the
lease i was like yeah i'm not living
here anymore i'm gonna play for the jets
like
give me a break can you at least have a
little sympathy for the situation
thank you bud uh thanks for joining us
and uh have fun in ohio
thank you man that's brady quinn
two pros and a cup of joe